yeah I don't want to welcome to this
video this is a new five-minute game and
they have the sound issues fixed yeah
there was a bit of a stupid thing I
tried something out and never and it
didn't work yeah i was gonna make and I
never put it back I'm I recognized that
the sound was bad but somehow I know
that switch went back in my recording
software whatever so I'm sorry for them
extremely bad audio over the last two
days so this should be better I mean I'm
still not satisfied but I kind of I
don't quite understand why I don't get
the sound term to something decent
anyway so let's see this is a absolute
main line position here from the from
the English opening and I like that
approach here for white it's a very
sound sound solid approach white tries
to play on the queenside where I have
more space and but like you cannot do
all that much it is a very own as
mentioned solid system for black so I
don't expect to yeah get something
fantastic out of this but it is a kind
of a grinding type of position let's see
main ideas yeah the b77 those pawns they
can become targets okay so he tries to
not give up the e-file all that quickly
but I have this and Queen a true so I
will eventually get to looks traded
yet the night to see 5 this is a
probably what he wants to do no he
doesn't I'd say five okay I'm not really
so sure about this it's f 5 it's
something that can prove to be a
weakness in the in this stage of the
game because there is some there is
little chance of an attack being
successful and f5 might might weaken him
so here I can go to a seven now all
right let's do that ask him about the
pawn and b6 it's not a move that he
should be particularly interested in no
it didn't play it okay night be three to
a five potentially after see a 95 at f/4
I could be something for black mr. be
cautious there that it doesn't doesn't
work okay so how why why is that working
if i take it
not if I take take 95 is a problem the
Queen can he go to e3 this is an
important thing hmm I wonder here I can
also take and play 92 of course just a
tacit but then night c5 happens the real
issue is this this night g5 business so
if i take and then maybe h4 maybe age
for here to get that hold the position
right f5 may be right at five the cell
might be good young yeah that might be
good III years the thing this isn't this
is an issue would love to go 95 so far
for night of success but membership is
quite clearly hanging and III mmm i
wonder if i should go III myself that
weakens the DAR the light squares my
temp g5 yeah anyway I think I after
mega-screen a one now and then efore
hangs if I have Queenie one immediately
there was a three-year didn't like that
however I also don't like my light
squares here quite clear Lisa p6 wow I
didn't think he has time for this thing
now 95 is a difficult move to meet Andy
for hangs now not sure everything's but
yeah I think maybe it does Queen B 7 is
the thing if I take you for butts 95 is
the real deal if I get the bishops
traded knight on d5 will be strong be 6
also makes the spawn very backward and
my night very safe on d5 so
okay so take it I have to check it out
first and now Bishop g7 our first
hopefully taking up let's take that
first Quincy forward be cool move in
every every piece would hang but it's
kind of difficult to believe so if I
check now we're check now I'm
threatening will potentially threaten
mates about if I get to the a drink all
right look hot looks stronger to put the
knife down and now yeah quinta a seven
traveling cream v8 and he cannot move
this night as Queen h7 is made ok so
here I can take I can take the Queen I
just wonder if i should go create a aid
it's probably even half a little bit
more precise I guess ok and now I'll
take and take your form
that's a very good ending I have 93 to
d5 the b6 porn is still still very weak
so it tries to probably play to see 75
morning so cannot take my porn which is
good check they actually have a look
that you cannot take my porn now which
is kind of stupid check check
so just some pressure on this section
should should do the trick ok ok also
yeah this is also good cat yeah I'm
comfortably catching the booze and yeah
instead the ICC sounds sounds weird and
this is something that has been a
constant thing over the years sometimes
anyway so let's not forget to switch on
this this I would it'll help even though
this wasn't a very tactically tense cam
yeah there are a couple of options here
but this is trading option on the a farm
it's super solid but term Oh interesting
computer actually things that this this
and this is good yeah this is something
yeah okay I didn't think for to think
about tactic see at all I just felt like
ok I'm getting this traded and now can
do little things there on the queenside
he played this very aggressive move with
you form this is an interesting moment
that I'm curious about so taking a
certainty right that I'm quite confident
about and now the engine just wants to
chance to capture I wants to play at
four oh sorry about that so TX the
engine wants to play f4 yes yeah night
g5 is still coming I did get it wants to
play of three it's that's an interesting
move f4f 395 and take whoa I'm not sure
if I would have done that looks quite
dangerous for human
ok took it the engine wants to play this
movie I was I wasn't sure about 95 but
and the computer takes it why does it
because he seven tanks ah ok ok ok I
mean I saw that this is not the end of
the world i'm not getting checkmated but
i was thinking if this is just hanging
but of course this hangs as well on his
seven so something like this there is
nothing special ok ok ok and if wait if
i do this um this cat this uh yeah Queen
g5 ok yeah neither five also irritated
me here but Queen g5 does the trick as I
have a cat have a fork Ian interesting
so that was strong ok i played this move
and now we can draw with neither for
which I did not see ready huh ok ok ok
ok yeah it seems I cannot run that cause
this is hanging with check Knight a5 e3
and now crew 2 h8 strong wolf with equal
play ok yes something like that
quitter 87 crazy yeah maybe I'm this is
looking dangerous if i get b 6 computer
gives equal probably am it wants to make
some kind of Perpetual as to be pawn
promotes okay this instead and now i'm
probably a bit better right not all that
much Queen h8 is a good defense yes sure
hmm okay you went here and now know it's
bad right here no I'm winning he
probably a queen h8 I didn't think about
that move it's a good defense of course
now he force coverage tactically and i
don't really i am not able to put more
pressure on and something like that is
easily covered and I haven't really
gained here I think the position is
probably equal this kind of thing what
the computer gives it looks like both
sides have problems doing doing
something this is weaker but I'm not
easily winning it like this this may be
98 this is and this is kind of yeah
everything cancels cancels out each
other so it's probably equal issue so
that was a bit I was lucky there that he
did not spot that and and him I'm just
substantially substantially better yeah
the best thing is just ending and T i'm
relatively easily winning I am so he had
some chances create and night f4 was a
draw ok guys thanks for watching